I want to follow up in the first segment
we talked about Shawn Spicer's recent
claim that when Donald Trump said Obama
wiretapped him he didn't really mean
wiretapping he meant some other kind of
amorphous thing that we haven't figured
out I want to talk about the resurfacing
of Trump advisor Kellyanne Conway we've
been following the accusations going
back and forth about the alleged Obama
wiretapping of Trump again totally
unfounded as of yet Congress gave a
deadline of yesterday for the White
House to provide some evidence of the
claim never happened the White House is
now telling people as I told you earlier
it wasn't a literal accusation but
Kellyanne Conway has now resurfaced
she's been much more scarce in the media
after a number of embarrassing
encounters with good journalists on TV
and she's not having a good return to
television she reappeared on the sunday
show on Sunday shows over the weekend
said it's possible that Barack Obama was
using a microwave to spy on Donald Trump
take a look do you know whether Trump
Tower was wiretapped what I can say is
there are many ways to surveil each
other now unfortunately you believe
there was an article this week that
talked about how you can surveil someone
through their phones through their
certainly through their television sets
any number of different ways and
microwaves that turn into cameras etc so
we know that that is just a fact of
modern microwaves that turn into cameras
we know that's just a fact of modern
life by the way my new favorite word
from Kellyanne Conway is ech cetera not
etc ech cetera
what is a secret camera on a microwave
even going to capture anyway who's
having meetings in front of their
microwave as I've mentioned before
Congress has asked the DOJ to provide
evidence about this they haven't done it
FBI director James Comey has urged the
Justice Department to denounce Donald
Trump's claims about this but we now
have Kellyanne Conway speculating about
household appliances that Obama could
have been using to spy on Trump John
McCain said to CNN quote I think the
president has one of two choices either
retract or to provide the information
that the
American people deserve because if his
predecessor violated the law
President Obama violated the law we have
got a serious issue here to say the
least I've been doing the opposite I've
been hiding my phone in the microwave to
prevent surveillance and clearly if
Kellyanne Conway is right I've been
doing this all backwards trumpets are
jumping all over themselves to defend
Kellyanne Conway links to the hacking of
toasters and other stuff come on guys
yes appliances can be hacked and there's
microwave technology that can be used to
eavesdrop from a distance but this is
sort of a semantic confusion when Donald
Trump said that Hillary Clinton bleached
her hard drives to cover up her email
scandal he seemed to think she literally
poured bleach on her hard drives
rather than software right sought
bleaching pseudo so-called bleaching
software easily one of the most absurd
things that Kellyanne Conway has said so
far in defense of Trump my top three
Kellyanne moments so far what are this
Obama could have spied on Trump through
a microwave the non-existent in Bowling
Green massacre and when she told Chuck
Todd after Chuck Todd asked a completely
reasonable question of her we might have
to reconsider our relationship with you
if this is how we're going to be treated
so Kellyanne Conway suggesting
microwaves might have been the mechanism
of for Donald Trump to be spied on by
Barack Obama they paint the picture as
if Barack Obama is personally sitting in
the White House residence observing
Trump through some kind of microwave in
the kitchen of Trump Tower I mean is it
the caricature is both absurd but
effective when you present like a visual
image of what you're suggesting to Trump
is because as we've talked about before
they are significantly low information
grifters who are going to be impacted by
this visual that Kellyanne Conway is
presenting here